mr vice president i'm speaking well
i'm speaking be important if you said
the truth if you don't mind letting me
finish
we can then have a conversation okay
please okay
on wednesday night vice president mike
pence and democratic candidate joe
biden's running mate kamala harris
faced off in a debate and let's just say
the whole thing
had hollywood talking i will not sit
here and be lectured by the vice
president
the politicians met up at the university
of utah
for a battle moderated by usa today
washington bureau
chief susan page the six topics
highlighted in the 90-minute event
included
donald trump and biden's records the
supreme court
race and violence in america the economy
the integrity of the election
and the handling of the novel
coronavirus covet 19
which president trump tested positive
for last week
one thing that's for certain don't let
it
dominate you don't be afraid of it
you're gonna beat it trump's handling of
the infectious disease
and recent comments dismissing the
severity of the pandemic
was addressed head on as each candidate
was spaced 12 feet apart behind
plexiglas the american people have
witnessed
what is the greatest failure of any
presidential administration in the
history of our country
alyssa milano one of the most outspoken
critics of trump and his administration
and someone who contracted covet 19 and
continues to suffer from its many
complications weighed in
tweeting quote the most important thing
joe and kamala will do
is listen to science and listen to the
experts hashtag vp debate
trump pence failure then there was this
moment
no but susan i this is important and i
want to add if mr vice president i'm
speaking i have i'm speaking
yeah you can have 15 more seconds and
then we'll give the vice president
so i want to ask the american people
yeah kamala shut that
ish down hard and naturally the moment
went hella viral uzo aduba tweeted quote
i'm speaking i'm speaking i hope every
little girl heard that
mark ruffalo also addressed to the
moment writing in part quote
the way mike pence constantly
interrupted and spoke over kamala harris
was the prime example of white male
supremacy and its common dismissal and
disrespect for black women
but nothing had people talking more than
the knights
guest star that fly is a great insult
oh and it stayed there and stayed there
and clearly just wanted to hang out huge
act of selflessness
darren chris gave a special thanks to
the bug megan kelly tweeted hashtag
flygate
while julia louis-dreyfus who played a
vice president on her hit
hbo show veep wrote quote well i wish we
had thought of this on veep hbo
who's controlling the fly it really is
like a storyline out of veep though
yeah i know now i feel like you're
attacking me it's kind of irritating
okay
can't make this stuff up people and
biden well his team
sees the moment in record time the
former vp tweeted this pick holding a
fly swatter right after the debate
wrapped up writing
pitch in five dollars to help this
campaign fly
well played and it just keeps getting
better biden's campaign even announced
on their website that they would be
selling
fly swatters that read get this truth
over flies
get it like truth over lies but it's
flies
anyway wednesday's broadcast marked the
first and only formal debate between the
vice presidential candidates
trump and biden are slated to meet again
for their second
presidential debate on october 15 and
again on
october 22nd let's just hope it goes a
lot smoother than the first debate
this is so uncomfortable
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment that
was really a
productive segment wasn't it keep
yapping man